Talk about this tweet that
you did on Saturday.
You wrote, You may lose your wife
You may lose your dog,
your mother may hate you.
None of those things matter.
What matters
is that you achieve success
and become free.
Then you can do whatever you lik
You're getting a lot of blowback
for that.
I stand behind that 100%
and you know why?
If you're an entrepreneur,
you know exactly what I'm talkin
because you need to sacrifice.
You have to work 25 hours
a day, eight days a week,
because your competitors in Mumb
or Shanghai
and they want to kick your butt.
You have to win
when you're young
and sacrifice everything
so that you achieve freedom
for your whole family later in l
That's the whole idea.
If you think you don't have to w
and you don't have to take risk
and you have to have commitment,
you're not an entrepreneur.
Just get a job and work
for somebody else.
Those words for people
that are motivated
to sacrifice personally,
to achieve
success, have freedom in their l
If you don't get it, don't worry
because you don't
fit the entrepreneurial mold.
And you know,
I've been saying that for 20 yea
If you really want to succeed,
you got to work your you-know-wh
and then some.
And then even more than that.
And now even more
because you're competing interna
you can say assets on this show.
Okay. Well, that's exactly what
If you're not ready to work your
you're not an entrepreneur, get
If that makes you uncomfortable,
I couldn't care less.
I've got to ask you and tell me
if I'm wrong. Here you are.
Are you encouraging people
away from the stock market?
Because I'm looking at your
what's on your wrist.
And you said
there are more tangible things
in the moment
that you would be investing in.
My watch collection
over the last
three years
has outperformed the S&P by almo
And so have you noticed this wat
There's only one of these read.
Of course,
this is a one of a kind app
made for Shark Tank season 15
This has already
appreciated 1400 percent.
I'd rather own
watches and stocks right now
if you can find them.
You said collectibles.
Establishment collectibles.
Yeah collectible watches. Very r
One of the kinds, that kind of t
Does that mean art as well?
Yes. Art's doing very, very well
There's alternative assets.
I tell people, wake up
and look at this stuff.
Besides stocks
you can make money on
the numbers that she just report
What do you think? Retail sales,
The most sense of over year, ove
That is absolutely stunning.
That is, you know,
to be talking about a recession
and have print over 6%
is almost unprecedented.
And so
something is really interesting
We have full employment
decade is for decades
to have unemployment this low.
Remarkable.
We're raising rates on the consu
Core inflation in food is really
And yet somehow
because everybody's got a job,
you get a print like that.
This is a rip roaring economy.
And if I were President
Biden, I'd take advantage
of what's happening here.
These are big numbers.
These are good numbers.
So he's going to speak well,
what do you mean, take advantage
What do you think he should do?
It's very, very rare
that you get a situation
where you have full employment,
you're raising rates
and you have retail sales number
And this strong is
just rarely ever happens.
And you want to take credit
for that here.
If the administration
because everybody's feeling pret
if retail numbers are up
6%, that's my whole point.
Now, how long can
this last
is what every small business in
is asking themselves
because they're trying
to make decisions every day
about how much money
they put into inventory
because they're supposed to be
seeing a slowdown.
Everybody's telling
there's a slowdown coming.
Where is it?
Yeah, the debate,
that's what we've been
do we have the right sort of met
to measure the economy
coming out of COVID?
Are we
are we using old analytics to st
something that is different?
Don, you're right about that.
The Fed is taking a lot of criti
specifically around housing.
The housing data is 18 month
old as it goes into the CPI numb
When you talk about inflation
and you keep fighting inflation
with more hikes, it's
because you're not really
taking into account
that housing prices are flatteni
in some markets rolling over.
And a lot of people are criticiz
the old way of measuring inflati
saying let's get housing out of
and let's look at core inflation
such as food and energy prices,
which are more current.
But housing is a lag indicator.
And so maybe what's happening
here is the Fed is fighting
like Don
Quixote, a fight
that he doesn't have to fight an
But that's not going to play sai
We're going to have two more rat
hikes, at least 25 basis points,
with that data.
I guarantee you the terminal rat
that's the rate
where the Fed stops is north of
Wow. That's remarkable.
You know, that's going to happen
He's just sitting in his office
saying oh, my goodness,
where did this come from?
Yeah.
Every time you kind of
see a look on his face, he's lik
what's next?
Can we talk about crypto for a m
Because you were actually a spok
for X, which was Sam Bankman-fri
Crypto Company.
Of course.
Now we have all seen
what's happened to it.
The larger question, though,
about what's happening to crypto
do you think that we're entering
kind of the Dodd-Frank
era of crypto
where there's going to be legisl
and regulation
if there's a silver lining
to this catastrophic collapse of
which cost so many people
so much, it's
that it poked the bear in Washin
and it's forced regulators to re
You've seen the heavy hand of Ge
he really hammered
crack at the FCC chairman.
It basically said no
more lending of crypto.
It's not a law yet for everybody
But he's saying, read the room.
I just shut down one exchange
and I'm going to do it
for everybody else. That keeps t
Keep doing this was called crack
And then this morning we hear th
the regulator in New York
has basically shut down
the minting of Binance tokens.
There are $64 billion of Binance
held in two wallets.
Well, I wonder who owns those
because if one of those people
wants to sell,
that's Binance down the drain.
So it's going to get very intere
Just real quick,
if we can do this as a lightning
because you said
that you would do everything you
because you were the spokesman
for the same language or Fiat.
You said you
do everything to track down the
Have you made any progress?
Oh, my goodness.
It's the whole narrative
on this situation for everybody
recovery We've heard about 4.2 b
and of the 1.2 billion
of the 400 million of cash.
Where is it?
We need the regulator
to actually give us the data.
You also tweeted
that you would work with him aga
Sandbag control. No, no.
If that was long before
I've been known on Shark
Tank for
over a decade,
that I will give money
to catastrophic outcomes
for entrepreneurs
who have learned their lesson
through failure.
Not when you're involved
in an alleged fraud.